>> Neil: LESS THAN TWO WEEKS
AWAY FROM TITLE 42 GOING AWAY AT
THE BORDER.
MANY ARE CONCERNED.
THE EAGLE PASS TEXAS MAYOR HERE
WITH US.
WHAT HAPPENS ON THAT DAY
ASSUMING THERE'S NO EXTENSION
THERE OR NO ALTERNATIVE PLAN?
>> WHAT HAPPENS -- FIRST OFF,
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
WE'RE GETTING PREPARED AS A CITY
TO HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
CROSS THE BORDER.
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WORKING TOGETHER WITH BORDER
PATROL, AND WE HAVE CREATED A
STAGING HERE IF WE HAVE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, TO
PROCESS THEM.
EAGLE PASS IS A VERY SMALL
COMMUNITY.
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
OUR CITY.
>> Neil: SO THAT SEEMS
INEVITABLE.
WEE HEARD FIGURES FROM 7,300 PER
DAY TODAY.
COULD EASILY TRIPLE.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS REALLY
POSSIBLE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
GETTING TOGETHER WITH FEDERAL
AGENTS IS VERY LIKELY.
ACTUALLY THEY SAY THERE'S
ALREADY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE JUST WAITING FOR MAY 23
ONCE TITLE 42 IS NO LONGER IN
EFFECT SO THAT THEY CAN COME IN.
SO WE'RE GETTING READY FOR THE
WORST.
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT ANYTHING
TO HAPPEN LIKE IT DID TO OUR
NEIGHBORS IN DEL RIO, WHERE YOU
HAVE AN INFLUX OF 15,000
IMMIGRANTS COMING IN TO THE
COMMUNITY.
SO WE WANT TO MAINTAIN ORDER.
>> Neil: I APOLOGIZE, SIR.
ARE YOU ANGRY AT THE MEXICANS
FOR NOT DOING MORE?
MANY SAY MEXICO IS DOING VERY
LITTLE TO ALLEVIATE THE PRESSURE
AHEAD OF THIS.
>> I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
MAYORS ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB.
WHAT I THINK WOULD HELP, A
STRONGER MESSAGE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, FROM OUR
PRESIDENT TO TELL THESE PEOPLE
WE'RE A NATION OF LAWS AND THIS
ISN'T OPEN BORDERS.
I THINK THE MESSAGE THERE IS
WHAT IS FAILING.
THESE PEOPLE THINK THAT WE'RE A
NATION OF OPEN BORDERS.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THOUSANDS
CROSSING THROUGH OUR CITY OF
EAGLE PASS, TEXAS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S VERY SAD.
TODAY WE GOT NEWS A LADY FROM
HONDURAS DROWNED IN THE RIVER,
SEVEN MONTHS PREGNANT.
WE'RE SEEING STORIES LIKE THAT.
IT'S VERY SAD.
AS A COUNTRY, WE NEED TO SEND A
STRONG MESSAGE TELLING THEM THAT
WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS AND WE
CA